all right hello everyone welcome to
another W from language design review
part of our language completeness and
consistency
series and we have three seemingly
simple topics for today they won't turn
out to be first one when is a link
object
valid oh
boy right so there are two kind of
invalid link objects and of course we're
going to be talking about various other
objects but just for concreteness we're
starting with link objects so there are
the syntactically invalid one
right you do link object of Fu or there
ones which are simply
expired um and as of right now we have
sort of various internal functions to
test whether something is alive so for
example if you were to copy that input
or to just re-evaluate that input then
the input yeah the input then you see
pre formatting goes away because that
was an object that was valid in my
session when I created that
but it is no longer valid in your
session
um so that's how you can tell that you
know right so that's one possible I mean
another possibility is that we would
maintain the
formatting but indicate invalidity which
I've seen
elsewhere
right um yeah I think we do that like on
like Channel objects they have kind of a
dynamic display of state of the
channel although the the issue of of you
know being able to tell at a glance
whether their valid is interesting but
there's a more fundamental issue of
being able you know a systematic method
for being able to tell whether things
like link object are valid from code
from from a
program right right I mean the whole the
whole question I raised that because in
in the kernel kernel objects I I wanted
to be able to accept link objects as
arguments then the question was well is
that thing actually valid should I care
should I test it before I incorporate it
into the kernel objective
and then I saw that you can just make up
your own link object expression so
nobody complains let's take the example
of a
URL okay got a URL f.com
sbar is it valid is it not valid if I
write
hxs colon SL whatever it's probably not
valid but if I have a plausibly valid
domain you know it might be down that
day is it valid is it not
valid see what I'm asking I mean there's
different senses in which things can be
valid
so and to
me you know like does a file exists Q
URL exists Q what does exist mean for
URL is it kind of 404 is it is it going
to DNS resolve you know what what level
of of exists is is
it right so I think right so I think we
can perhaps separate you know system
internal things to completely external
things like link object note object sell
objects you know input stream output
streams I think those all have sort of
well defined Notions of is this thing
open and you know can you dreference it
and get non- junk output out of it um
well does it point to a thing that's
actually there which is the same issue
with the URL well it's it's I mean it's
not entirely the same issue in that
uh you know the the URL is a thing that
exists in the world Beyond wol from
language uh and and and when you're
dealing with that world you know we we
had better have provided you the you
know the apis for doing that but uh this
class of objects are objects that only
the wolf from system knows whether or
not they exist okay what about other
knowledge anywhere okay what about
parallel parallel process is parallel
wol
kernels yeah there there I have a very
specific notion of validity and so a
kernel object knows whether it's valid
or not and I mean same as with URLs I
mean same question is file name is a
file name valid if the file exists or is
it valid if it's
syntactically correct I mean if you have
a file name a named pipe that yeah if
you say create file then you always have
an invalid file name as argum by
definition right and if you so I think I
mean atically with all of these I mean
most of these are not things that you
are supposed to to input right they are
produced by some by some
Constructor and the same problem happens
whenever you design a data type right
you have your objects and you need to
know whether the objects are valid yeah
so that you can format them correctly
and accept them as arguments and and so
you see always see in code that
implements data types you always have a
some kind of validity predicate and each
one has its own and so my plea here
would be to introduce systemwide valid
Cube re that could be
used bya overloading for all kinds of
objects vality whether valid is the
right term or whether it's active Q or
something yeah I think active Q is
probably a better name certainly for the
system internal ones right link object
we have a very well defined notion of is
this an open link that we can read and
read or write from right uh note
notebook object cell object maybe also
process object um certainly input stream
and output stream you know like what are
some other words other than I mean valid
I don't
welled inter well formed isn't the right
point well well well formed isn't the
point the point is not that it's formed
the point is that you can actually do
something with it right like that and
just to reply to that to further
emphasize right that link object is well
formed it doesn't point to anything in
the current session but it's a
well-formed link object
yeah this isn't a a good name but
instantiated Q I mean you know that uh
conceptually I think that's a similar
sort of thing yeah or exists Q maybe
accessible
Q mean there are other classes of of
objects like interpolating functions or
Solutions of partial differential
equations I don't and they all they
always have a particular head but if you
type one in you get chunk right so there
is a definite notion of validity for
anything that that we call an object but
well but I I I think that's pushing it
the this notion way too far I mean any
expression can be valid or invalid in
that sense right I no not if it's a
purely symbolic expression that doesn't
pretend something RL is a purely
symbolic expression right it it has no
other than format values it has no
definitions attach to it I mean that
does have a notion of validity and that
it you know it's marked valid Q
internally
um something about this feels similar to
the discussion we had in last week's
hyper architecture check-in meeting
where the issue at hand was um uh Larry
was wanting to add some code to check if
like a task object was still running or
not and if it was running cancel it and
I think what's interesting about that is
that like it's a question of you want to
do some operation if some condition is
true and you know that's that's like
there's a name for this it's time of
check the time of use it's like a
standard thing in software that can
sometimes go wrong and I wonder if if
that applies here right where if it's
almost fundamentally not a well-formed
thing to ask if something is quote
unquote valid if that thing can become
invalid you know through no Act of the
programmer you know anything you have
any control over right like if you if
you were to write on one line in a
program yeah URL valid QE that website
could go down the next millisecond and
the operation you would do next would
fail so it's not really necessarily a
meaningful thing to ask is this thing
valid at this instant um because it
could change any given moment and and
Link object has this you know I mean in
the way that a link
object uh you know might be become
dissociated I mean one way is that it
doesn't correspond to a system object
inside the kernel the other is that it
corresponds to a system object inside
the kernel but the other side of the
link died and the colonel doesn't know
it yet yeah right so I mean the basic
point is all of these okay the
interpolating function is a different
case because because the interpolating
function I mean once it's valid it's
valid for all time whereas a link object
you could write you could close or write
a an e off to to the link object and
then the same expression is no longer
valid okay what what do you think of the
name currently valid
Q I mean I think I'm I having trouble
evaluating the you know any of these
possible suggestions without a better
understanding of what Roman's hoping to
achieve like what the The Next Step
would be assuming that this function
whatever we call it it returns true or
false what happens next can you
dreference
the the
object is really the
question that's what this is
answering yeah for example I want to
write a function that accepts an
interpolating function as argument so I
would write F
of
iore fun question mark valid Q well just
because it's valid Q doesn't mean it's
useful for you right it doesn't mean it
is because that guy Roman let me finish
Roman let me finish Roman let me
finish it's doesn't mean that you know
it's defined for the right number of
variables or defined for the domain
you're interested in or or anything
right I mean and there are ways you can
test each one of those things but you
know just because it it it just because
it's been marked valid cube in the
kernel table doesn't mean it's at all
useful for
you okay so look here the take a step
back and ask you to write a formatting
rule for interpolating function so you
need some kind of predicate in that
formatting right which is you don't
really care how many variables it has
but was it is it is it valid I mean that
was that well it's quite literally does
it pass system private valid
Q because yes and I would like to have a
system valid que instead of a system
private okay so listen listen I've got a
claim I don't have the names but I've
got a claim for what this what what
there's two ideas one is valid format Q
okay is it of which this would pass
valid format Q it wouldn't pass it if
you had seven arguments that were
symbolic here okay valid format Q
currently valid Q This
fails this this here in the case of
interpolating function currently valid q
and valid format Q will always return
the same answer in the case of a link
object they will return different
answers in
general and currently valid Q I claim
should actually sort of try and do the
dreference so for example currently
valid Q on a
URL should actually try and I don't know
do a read from the URL or something to
determine if it's currently valid now
okay you you could ask okay so here's
here's a here's a slicing of that
something could be currently valid for
reading but not currently valid for
writing and that's a subtlety yeah I
mean you know the in the case of Link
objects
um I I I actually don't know of a a
general test that could be applied in
you know re uh in in any reasonable
state that the link object would be in
that would give you this
information is I
mean what what the what the formatting
rule is based off of is you know some
internal uh you know test that Steve
Wilson gave me a decade ago which is
presumably you know does this thing
appear in the table of known link
objects to the kernel and therefore it
will attempt to write to it but or read
from it but there's no guarantee that
that operation will succeed and or not
hang your kernel okay so yeah well and
and and this was the class of test I was
thinking of when I gave my input to this
agenda item was basically uh you know it
is this expression connected to an
internal system
object okay I've got a suggestion guys
yeah I got a suggestion my suggestion is
we got these two things valid format Q
currently valid q and currently valid Q
could have a second argument different
depending on what the objects are here
that gives the you know the sense of
whether what what does currently valid
mean like you know file exists or
something or it could be but currently
valid
Q by default with one argument would
make a reasonable heuristic decision on
what it means so currently valid Q for a
file if the file doesn't exist would be
false so this is mostly a function for
objects with external State yeah that's
correct that's what it is and and the
internal State
objects this is still useful even for
the external State object valid format Q
is still useful yeah that would be
useful for example as an argument test
simple argument test without wasting
time yes but now I don't like the name
because format suggests to me that it's
somehow related to
formatting right okay so I me that was
the sense that I when I suggested
well-formed Q I mean maybe it's not a
great name either that was the sense in
which I thought that function would work
that it's it doesn't have to hit the
network or the file system it's based
purely on the structure of the symbolic
object
valid structure
Q is valid Q not no it's no that because
we're all confused every time we bring
up valid Q every time we bring up valid
q q we get confused because actually
there are two different things right
that's why we should separate it valid
structure que because if you see that in
a piece of code if it says valid
structure Quee of Link object okay you
know that that's not going to test the
link object you know it's just testing
the
structure currently valid
Q you know that that is a Time dependent
thing it's not just testing the
structure so for immutable or internal
things valid structure Q would be two
for everything that was produced in a in
an approved way right left without of an
interpolation opening opening a link and
uh
yeah it's all valid structure Q I mean
that link object at the top there would
be valid structure Q true but it would
be currently valid Q
false yes I mean that's that's the
function I'm have on if it's called
valid start Q okay I can probably live
with
that okay you were asked to that one I
thought you were asked for currently
valid CU but no no because I don't care
about the I want code that accepts only
syntactically correct inputs
and I mean that the internal code works
the same if you look at the the library
the link Library the kernel bindings
then when those functions return a link
object they first check whether it's
syntactically valid and then when they
actually need to use it then they
actually check whether it's the right
well well and and to be
clear
uh
the um right the interpolating function
example is testing not only that it
syntactically valid but semantically
valid which maybe
sure yes but I mean the the way to do
this is to set some internal bit when
you create it and then you don't have to
waste any Spa time okay but fine but
does are we H happy with valid structure
Q on an interpolating function if it is
not semantically correct then valid
structure Q is
false yes
yeah okay well that's what I'm proposing
here and I I'm proposing that as a kind
of an escape valve we have second
arguments probably for both of these
things that can give more color to
whether something what it means to be
currently
valid yeah Ian I'm imagining like it
seems like there are a lot of functions
in the system like say like take pack
object Q right as an example that whose
current behavior is basically what this
new valid structure CU thing is they do
basic syntactic check checking so to
speak of the structure of
objects yeah well maybe we can a bunch
of these functions yeah you can look at
all of the Star q asteris q functions
and the well some some are type some are
type tests which are useful but others
are simply okay so here's another one
currently valid to you know this isn't a
good name but actively test do the Ping
those kinds of
things as um yeah so you would not only
be content with the link object being
open but you would actually try to you
would actually tickle it and see whether
it's still alive right so let's just
take a little look which could hang the
kernel so I'm not sure that's a good
idea well I understand I understand but
but that that's you know that's what
you're signing up for so to
speak
um okay let's just have a quick look
here at um at which of these what's the
fastest way okay so file exists Q I'm
going to I'm going to list um
candidates for for things related to
this file exist Q file format q
no finite field element primitive q no
okay hold on let's just take a look
here array
q no no not really right it takes Rank
and Q ask Q what the hell is ask
Q probably something for the question
framework oh
yeah um maybe not as many Q functions as
we thought yeah there not as many of
these yeah most most are type type of
property tests binary image Q yeah
that's that's more of a Content
test bite array Q it's not again it's
it's a type test
um I mean I wonder if it' be fair that
to imagine this hypothetical valid
structure Q function is being keyed on
the head right so you it might be
something like you may not there might
be situations where you don't care
necessarily what the type is you just
want to know that whatever it is maybe
maybe there's like three types that you
generally accept exactly exactly you
just want to know garbage or not okay so
the same be that currently valid Q would
over time be defined for all our
internal data types and be available via
up values for implementers of new data
types so so it looks like bio sequence Q
is such a
function well but that bio that returns
true on strings
right or I guess there's I know
there's the principal uses message is
returns true if the argument is valid
biosequence expression and false
otherwise yes but what it means is
something a little different than what
you think it means okay I agree that
okay so let's write that down here
because the point there is that I think
that if you give
it
um if you feed
interesting interesting does it does it
want to have a bio sequence
head I guess it
does inputs with heads other than bio
sequence will be false according to the
documentation okay so it's a type tester
really
MH but there's one interesting case that
is Association Cube which is a bit more
than just telling whether it's an
association because Association
expressions can be invalid because right
I mean if they the internals are so this
is kind of a candidate for okay so valid
structure Q would apply to assoc
Association Q valid structure Q on an
association right so right Association Q
of an empty Association is true but
Association Q of an association
containing blank is not true because
it's not backed by right that's just a
pattern it's not backed by uh
map I think it's like anything where the
head like these functions don't just
check heads they check that the internal
contents are semantically consistent so
I think biosequence Q would actually
fall into that same category maybe not
for Strings but for something with head
bio sequence right you could imagine
valid structure CU of you know
underscore bio sequence would just call
bio sequence Q of that same value I mean
just type Association right right the
the goes to eight have just a blank as
the second argument then it'll give you
false or any any any
junk well I wouldn't call that junk but
it's a normal expert not backed by a
hashmap right I mean that's very useful
if you're going to be calling
matchu and two argument Association
first key is a goes to
six I wonder whether there's some way of
indicating that
it yeah um I just put sorry yeah
uh I wonder if there's some way of
indicating that this is head keyed so in
other words that because in this
Association case you might say oh if it
isn't a valid structure
it means it's garbage but that's not
garbage the thing you have
there right it's
really but it's not an association
right right it's not an association in
the sense that it's not backed by a
hashmap but it is an
association association correct yeah and
it's also like it's a semantically
meaningful pattern in some sense um
right but but you couldn't for example
do key extraction right I don't think
you can you know do that Association of
you know key of A I don't think that'll
work because it's not a true
Association
yeah
um well but okay so my my only concern
here is valid structure if it's false
suggests it's garbage but it isn't in
fact correct that it's garbage it's just
that it's not
behaving yeah it's garbage it's garbage
in the sense that you could not pass it
as an argument to a function that
accepts an association like Association
map or any any function that so but you
could still use I mean it is a symbolic
expression just like but it's not an
association
right Nick is pointing out symbol q and
video Q are
examples molecule
Q right audio but but hold on a second
the thing about something like molecule
Q is it's asking two questions it's
asking both is the head molecule and are
the inerts molecularly appropriate no
it's documented that a molecule with
improper veilance will issue a message
but is still molecule
Q oh yeah that's the other issue Q
functions can be quite uh inconsistent
about what they do with edge cases well
but okay so for
us is is a molecule within correct
veence uh
valid structure
Q I think no I think if it if it you
know um you know
EG if something issues a
message that makes it an invalid
structure that implies it's an invalid
structure it's not clear to me why this
decision was made about molecule Q um
there nothing in the mentation suggest
why it's useful this way and not the
other
way and we don't have any molecule
adjacent folk here so right it may no
atoms yeah I mean you know the real
question
is yeah your question is valid structure
Q of
exper if
true indicates
that um you can do with
exper what you can do
with sort
of any I don't know what fully
processed object with the head of
exper well ex no because of the State
issue you mean I guess you can attempt
it but you'll get a a fail fail thing
rather than a well for the currently you
get a different
failure yeah I mean look currently valid
Q is things that don't evaluate because
they evaluated to failure you're done
right currently valid Q is things that
sit there as objects but might not in
fact instantiate properly good example
of currently valid Q is scheduled task
active
Q I
see so currently value of a task
object
does task active mean it's running or
does task active just means it isn't it
isn't you know it's meaningful and could
run well I I guess scheduled task active
Q is is the depricated name it's not
clear what it was replaced with
uh there isn't a task object well okay
so so who knows what that like it I
think there's an act like there's an
active there's some property of task
object you can
read yes right where I believe it means
you know it has you know nonzero it has
a positive number of
repetitions uh
which number in the sense that it
something's currently that it's
currently running on its last one I
believe is what it means yeah there an
example in the documentation suggests uh
a cloud scheduled task that could be
stopped and scheduled task active Q
would then return false but then then
you could restart that task and it would
return true
again I minut ELC on a live stream is
pointing out a syntactically valid
object can have a semantically valid
referent that happens to it
selfrepresent an IND
Direction
in which can what syntactic sematic is a
false dichotomy I don't understand this
maybe it refers to something we talked
about earlier all right look I think we
have a direction here let's try and fill
out currently valid q and valid
structure q and see what they apply to
okay so whe they Mak
sense one question I assume does anybody
disagree with the proposition that valid
structure Q of a failure
object can be true like it's not like
all failures are invalid it's just
absolutely failure yeah
okay it's a Mal failure yeah if it's a
malform failure then it's false but if
it's a if it's a
successfully
formed uh you know failure object then
valid structure que is absolutely true
for it yeah I agree too yeah just wanted
to check that I think that's that's a
litmus test like are we actually
understanding that this is not like
something like uh well we're reading its
name valid structure Q it's not valid Q
which will be completely unclear what
the hell it is yeah
okay um all right
onward message
reissue right so a
common uh so we have an example here of
a utility function that you know sort of
appears
periodically where right we want to test
parameters and we can do that by calling
pre-existing fun functions um but of
course we don't want to be issuing
messages from
random
heads um and
so we you know so basically we run the
test quieted and then you know if it
failed issue a new message with the new
thing and it might be much nicer if we
had something where we
could uh you know just have a single
function
that uh you know did the thing and
reissued it and so after thinking
through this um I I don't know that
anybody has Pro uh has uh proposed this
exact thing but my proposal is that we
want something like irrespective of the
name a function like message reissued
which takes the expression and then says
well map messages issue them as head but
it also tells you whether or not a
message was actually issued so you can
use this as a predicate and not just as
doing the uh how does it tell you if a
message was issued I mean doesn't it
just return oh I see this thing has a
return value the side effect is issue
the message the return value is true or
false whether it it it actually did the
reissuing whether it actually issued a
message I understand
don't we have another function that
tells you it doesn't check effectively
tell you whether a message was issued
yes so so you you'll notice that
uh
um well I guess I guess I guess you know
Danny decided to write this in a
different way where he
just I mean this example comes from
Danny's code but you know we can
really yes I'm pretty pretty sure that
you are the person who wrote level Q um
okay
uh um great so you're here and you don't
even recognize your own code I rarely do
it looks too smart okay well maybe Jose
suggested it to you and you're just the
person who committed it got
it uh
so um right but you could also have
envisioned writing this as you know a
quiet of check of blah and then have a
second
argument that issues the messages and
return true but this is sort of a
sufficiently common idiom that it seems
like maybe we want
to
um do this and there there is this util
there is this wfr called message replace
which does just uh reissuing
part
um and uh you know I'm not not sure I
haven't looked at the details of how
it's uh written and Rick was invited but
apparently he can't make it which um I I
don't think is if we really want into
the dig into the details of message
replace we would need him if if we don't
then um but you know I don't think I
think I think his message replace is
sort of too General and too confusing I
think what we want is something
simpler that just allows you to you know
change to head maybe changed to
tag um and and sort of returns it but
you know since it's the first time I'm
actually proposing this thing it might
also be good to see if anybody else has
any thoughts about whether this is a
sufficiently useful thing to be well
okay so the issue is there's a couple of
points here so first point is the
Cosmetics of deep inside your code
there's some message being ass sued and
you want to spoof where it comes from
right for and right and so right now I
mean this is a very simple example of
you know testing an argument but right
it could also be right somewhere deep
inside your code you're calling solve
but you don't want to see random solve
messages you want to see you know my
function
messages right do you want yeah do you
want the same message content as the
solve thing or do want something
different usually the same is okay I
won't say that's
perfect it's sometimes different I mean
yeah we could we could have message
spoof and also message replace there's
room in the world for
both or or it could just be I I so want
a symbol name
[Laughter]
spoof but I mean looking at a step back
it would also be useful just to know
whether certain arguments are acceptable
without tying them to messages I mean
Ian I mean I have this problem all the
time when I write parallel
implementations of certain functions so
I have to read through the documentation
figure out all the 10 different calling
sequences it would be much easier if I
could just do a trial call and if it
works then I can accept the argument
otherwise
I will go go sequential so I think that
something like checking whether
something is valid as an argument
without necessarily issuing a message
would also be
useful well I I suppose if we gave a
second argument to valid I mean maybe
this is pushing it too far but if we
gave valid structure q a second argument
of like what to test for so we could
have like level spec and then it could
I saying something like that might be
useful to evaluate its argument so what
you want what Roman wants is
um you know he wants something like
check argument structure of f of blah
blah blah which doesn't evaluate its
arguments right yes that strikes me as
impressively difficult to
obtain
but also what what what would the Syntax
for that be would that be like one goes
to something two goes to string level
spec no I would actually take the very
expression that I want
to eventually evaluate and first do a
test drive but I understand that in
general this is impossible and what we
see about is is quite a bit of a you
don't
know you won't know if something will
evaluate without without evaluating it
is I think what it comes down I mean
that that example there doesn't really
have any structure in the second
argument so it might be that the level
spec would be different in that case
than if the second argument were a 10
Deep nesty list or something like
that I mean this question of whether F
of
XYZ is very similar to the valid
structure Cube question well but that's
for output that's for in inert things no
I know I know valid structure goes
through things but this is something
where do a test drive first pass is it
obviously
wrong you know
look it's kind of like
uh check obvious
things plausible arguments
Q um read mind
bracket
well I mean there are things where we
definitively
know that well we well we only
definitively know them if we State what
our expectations are right like a level
spec right I mean there's a well
defined uh okay notion of what's a valid
level spec but you need to tell D
function which of the arguments is the
level spec okay let me an example okay
that okay this relates to a thing I
really wanted to do for the language we
have syntactic
correctness okay for the language we
know if it's syntax valid we don't
have sort of this is relating to my
semantic grammar stuff for
English you
know you
a you know a cactus cannot be happy so
far as we
know or mine is very happy yeah
I the pl the plants the plants in my
plants versus zombies garden when I
water them they clearly smile and become
happy okay all right unik unlike the
zombies um the
uh
[Music]
um
um oh God why am I not coming up with
something
[Music]
um I mean it's related to type type
correctness yeah yeah yeah but I mean
there there's there's a whole idea which
we've been exploring a lot in the case
of natural language of when do things
when are things s semantically you know
a mountain can't go to the
store just just
doesn't true you know a mountain is a
fixed object it doesn't take a trip to
the
store except
poetically and so similarly in our
language this basically doesn't mean
anything just as even you know plot sinx
Fu doesn't mean anything even though in
principle I mean just like if I type in
log Open Bracket close
bracket okay in principle log Open
Bracket close bracket could be a
symbolic expression that I can pull
apart and use for things but we have
decided that it is sufficiently
plausibly meaningless that we carrot it
and we give a
message you w know the plot sinx is
semantically invalid until you tried to
evaluate Fu inside of
plot
that
point what would that work or does or
does plot check the unevaluated
fu BR well plot gets the UN if you
define Fu outside of plot as you know
list x01 or whatever that will work
okay it may only be plot that does that
at the moment like I I think like
parametric plot won't
um right and also assuming that X has no
Global value
correct right you know food would have
to be something that is at
evaluation you know or upon
evaluation a valid iterator for plot or
valid variable spec for plot
right but one can imagine other examples
like this where the semantics are
slightly implemented slightly
differently and where it absolutely
matters whether you do or do not
evaluate the thing as to whether it's
semantically
sensible what are the I'm having a
little trouble like understanding um
what are the use cases where you would
want to check this property of like is
this function call valid with but not
actually do the function call if it's
invalid I mean I can think of some
obvious like maybe if a fun has side
effects code analysis I mean you this is
what I wanted for code analysis that
somebody who types this in it's it
should be flagging this just like it
Flags a Miss
spelling
okay no my so so so so Connor here's an
example that is you know real okay
suppose I'm writing some you know
special plot
function and I want it to you know work
the same as plot but it's you know doing
something
special so how do I test that the second
argument of my plot function is correct
let's give a more concrete case you want
a function called you know F plot that
is just going to feed itself to plot but
with special options set for plot right
and the question is can you test F plot
on the way in or do you have to wait
until it gets all the way to plot and
then fail
if you write code that's specific to you
know the the argument structure you want
for flu plot flu plot you can write test
code for it but that
you what I'm trying to say is that we
should be tempering our our hopes with
reality here this is basically going to
be a
syntactic um task plus maybe Case by
casee
details if we want to go that far I
don't think Roman does he's he's got
General functions to deal with he can't
afford to to write special code for
every possible input to to test for
validity okay what I'm suggesting here
is something I've really wanted for a
long time it is semantic
plausibility okay there are cases just
like there are cases where you can
confuse syntax coloring and you can have
things which are syntactic correct but
or or for example scoping but the
scoping coloring doesn't know
that yes that does happen it's rare
though it's very rare and the question
is I think with x equals x does
it but but that's not commonly done even
even though it's legitimate that's
right um I must be I'll have to find a
different EX example okay all right fine
there are cases where you can do it
um
question I mean okay so first point is
semantic
plausibility that you know it's just
like spellchecking yes there are words
that are you know correct
spelling you know there are words we
didn't know like like we didn't know the
word I think um I think as of yes
yesterday at least we didn't know the
word poly
algorithm okay which is a you know it's
a somewhat valid
word i i i i protest to use of the word
we no no I I said we as in the
spellchecking
system Oh I thought it wasn't in our
dictionary yeah I thought you had
elevated yourself to royalty for a
moment no I was I was not really um they
no but I
mean my point is if we could do the same
sort of thing with spellchecking this is
what we have plannned for several years
for code assistance and we could tag
something where somebody says this thing
here if we could put a squiggly line
underneath the foo here we will be very
happy ultimately I think that boils down
to syntax
well I mean that that putting right
putting the squiggly there is right that
right that's a different I mean I guess
the question is is this before or after
is this
having uh it's this putting the squiggly
line in real time or is this you know
after you've clicked on check code
because if you click check code we could
absolutely do that if you want this in
real time well now you need the box
barer to somehow figure out inside the
second assume that there's some check
code mechanism okay let's not worry
about the implementation the question is
you know what we want there is a soft
failure of there's a squiggly but you
could still evaluate
it yeah that seems absolutely
plausible and that's what we were trying
to do with the code assistance project
and that's what you know various llm
plays that we've tried to do are pushing
for the same thing you know the llm is
kind of telling you what it thinks is
kind of normal and customary so to
speak and
uh but normal customary comes down
eventually to this came up in a
different mail today but to a BNF for
the
expression um pre-evaluation based on
the the documented
usage yes so fu is supposed to be a list
or you know some such and and and it's
not not therefore so it really does come
down to syntactic
checking in that case it does I think
there other cases where it isn't I mean
the interesting thing is if you type a
correct list of X comma 01 there it does
syntax color it so it knows about that
list and so it could probably just turn
that R if if it's not well I know in
that particular case but you know okay
here we've got a case where the heck is
it doing there why isn't it no because
they the wrong kind of places right well
I know but why isn't that flagged as an
error why is that why does that look
like it's just completely harmless yet
it's wow it's wet it's wet on the right
I yeah I just did a I just pressed shift
enter why on Earth does that not
indicate okay this is something for our
user assistance meeting I I think this
has been brought up in user assistance
before and it just hasn't been
implemented okay well well I'm provid
and and and and probably the reason this
wasn't initially implemented was
because uh you know it was a somewhat
later concept that uh that some kinds of
uh
highlighting uh should not happen when
the cursor is in the right place so you
wouldn't want this highlight to pop up
as you're typing um uh but if you move
the cursor away then yes it should pop
up okay fine so that's just a case that
should be covered yes but
agreed you know there are things here I
don't know whether this is valid I think
this is valid I think there is a a
meaning to this isn't there not got a
headless
expression no this one oh oh oh
oh I don't think plot
has doing discontinuities like like and
great
does it's possible that it's one of
those things that was at one point and
then but it was never documented because
we had the exclusions
option and so okay my point is that this
should be tagged as being
implausible best imp plausible if not
just wrong I mean in in in in principle
there's nothing wrong with that but the
the problem is that this is re we
benefited for a lot of our current
syntax highlighting we benefited from
the natural structure of our
documentation and we were able to you
know to not have to do a lot of work by
basically just processing our
documentation uh the structure of our
documentation does not help us with
cases like this though if if we tried to
make presumptions from what we saw in
the documentation it would go wrong too
many times for it to be having worth
doing in the first place well John John
for it would it would take the
documentation for plot itself correct
yes and and wouldn't that and by by
which by which I mean the usage messages
right right right and don't they only
allow list of line three or am I wrong
about that the the problem is that there
are many cases where uh the I mean for
plot yes actually for plot no because
there's a dot dot dot case for including
symbolic rappers okay can I make a
suggestion
here okay yeah so even in plot it goes
bad and in other functions it will be
worse okay right one possible idea is to
have
a I wouldn't call it normal on customary
I would say communal Garden BNF which
means you know so the question is there
are things where it's like you know or
more to the point our kind of patterns
right there there's the communal Garden
pattern which is like this is a very
common case this is what it should do
there's
the sort of well it didn't mean there's
the kind of there's allowed patterns and
there's maybe something in the middle
that's the kind of normal and customary
patterns not a weird
case and you know clearly I think we all
have agreed for years that it would be
useful to have a pattern you know we
we've opposed making a patent
specification for what the argument
structures for all the function should
be because there are cases that are
still quite valid but they're more like
expert weird cases am I making
sense so the question is is it worth our
while to come up with what we could call
normal and customary let's say
patterns that admittedly don't cover the
weird cases what do we do with it let's
say we had a broad coverage of normal
and customary patterns what would we
then
do you know could we imagine some
ux that indicates oh there could be a
problem here but you don't you know it's
not really important I bet there's a way
to do that I don't think we F that
through and that would be quite useful
because it's kind of like you see that
it's not following the normal and
customer but it's okay and you have an
easy way to kind of type okay let me
give an analogy okay if you say F Open
Bracket wherever I'm typing where I'm
typing yeah wrong place
um if I say F Open Bracket oh because
we've done okay let's let's imagine that
we get rid of that bracket okay there
okay
now
um uh you know that's indicated oh
there's something fishy with that that
Open Bracket but that Open Bracket goes
back to being a uh you know a calm color
as soon as I fill something in so my
question would be if you've got
something you know could we have
something where we indicate that it
isn't normal and customary but there's a
very easy and natural way that you are
continuing to type and thereby saying
well I actually want to use that anyway
even though you just told me it wasn't
normal and
customary see what I'm saying CU I mean
the other case if if you just see it
flash up with some weird coloration in
this case that's perfectly okay because
you just know oh that wasn't complete
I'm going to keep going well here's an
example of such things today if I look
at a
module uh you know code with a module in
it my normal expectation is that
everything inside there is going to be
black or module colored except oh wait
look there's a global inside there oh
but I did want a global in this
particular case so that's
okay
sure yeah that that's right but I mean
so my my claim is that if we had the
coverage to have the patterns for
everything we could do ux that makes
sense which suggests that we should try
and get those patterns which we could
start off with documentation maybe using
LM to get some of it and and and and and
that and that is my big concern the you
know the level of information that we're
getting now as I said comes straight
from the documentation and it's not
error free from the documentation I
would I would estimate that uh you know
documentation as it's being added has
maybe something like a two or 3% error
rate and that's manageable these turn
into bug reports and you know sometimes
the people who wrote the documentation
don't know what to do so it comes to
somebody like Brian V or myself and we
fix it and we can manage
that uh but so yeah a two or three%
error rate we can manage a a 75% error
rate that's that's a real problem right
but I mean we can also reduce that error
rate by looking for example at our tests
and seeing whether there are ones that
are conflictive tests that once supposed
to generate a message and are they
conflictive so to speak with what we've
said with the patterns that we
give I'm more worried about the case
where some function definition just has
a great big dot dot dot in it and you
know where then that converts into well
anything goes and we don't have any well
and plot plot falls into that category
yeah I we actually already you know
there are some functions where we have
to take the dot dot dot version and and
uh intentionally exclude it from our
current rule set because dot dot dot
doesn't really mean dot dot dot it just
means well look at the above and kind of
you know make a human presumption about
what
follows
yes well okay fair enough um that's not
a majority of functions though right
it's not a majority larger fraction than
you think yeah it's a lot okay I mean
you know we could even give you a count
because those you know those exclus
markings they're in the author notebooks
and it would be easy enough to see how
many there are but I mean I've added
quite a number of them I've seen many
more so okay I think it's worth our
while to explore further this idea of
making pattern specifications for all
argument struct you know for the for
normal and customary argument structures
I think that's useful I think it's a
really good
direction now next let's just loop back
to the original question here about
message spoofing I mean that that's fine
and we don't have to answer this here
but my main concern is I don't know how
that happens I don't even know where it
happens in the company with what group
who manages it and
such right you just volunteered John no
I think it's I think it brunches off
from documentation I think it's part of
that enhancing that and that group you
know needs additional help so yeah I
think that's where it should go
um but message if that were done we
could then add more infrastructure to
the front end that infrastructure
doesn't exist right now because we
didn't need it but we could add it it
wouldn't be crazy um and then we could
support better syntax highlighting as
well actually you know Michael and Eric
wein folks they they who did w from
language data they might be a good place
to go for
this let's explore
that okay
all right spoofing for a second and then
we should wrap here very soon um it
might be relevant to mention one of the
topics we discussed there was nrow
handling this morning was the question
of how do we turn you know functions
that currently issue messages into
failures automatically which I think is
kind of related to what's happening here
because it makes me think that like if
if such a function existed right then
instead of doing this what to me at
least seems somewhat hacky message
reissuing idea
where you're kind of catching a message
and then you know yeah raising it again
just make have the outer function deal
with the fa wait you got two different
use cases here these are two I think
very different use
cases sometimes you just want to change
the the header on a message but
otherwise let things continue to
evaluate sometimes you want check and
you catch the message and issue a
failure return of failure instead these
are very different use cases both
important but different well I think my
thought was that the relation is if you
can catch the message at the lower level
like you mention an example of like a
function that internally uses solve
somewhere right if instead you you you
catch that message and transmute it into
a failure at the point you call solve
you can just use normal control flow you
know however you want to get it back up
to your top level function where you
would be using message reissue and
instead at that point just process that
failure object however you want you know
print the same message print a new
message that uses some of the arguments
from the original message whatever it
may be um um l i mean so so so I mean
the use case for this is you know things
like log plot calls plot and I don't
want to you know have all you know
logplot do all of the option processing
again um you know but I want you know it
to come back as log plot messages
instead of plot
messages you know in the case where you
know it doesn't necessarily return
unevaluated it just says you know hey
this setting was wrong
or um you know that sort of thing yeah
my use case might be I call Salve Salve
throws some message from together but
continues on its merry way and gives a
result you know I mean yes I might want
to just suppress that together message
entirely but if I don't I I I don't want
to stop everything dead at that point
and not get the solv result okay listen
listen one of the problems is this if we
were to just reskin a message spoof its
head it's going to mess up documentation
of that message you know if if you've
replaced that message with a you know a
solve message and it was really a
together message that was you know
reskinned for solve everything is going
to get confused we've been doing this
for a long time it's not a general
message yes assuming it's not a general
message I'm afraid we have been doing
I know we've been doing this but if we
add this to user code it's going to get
much more
confused but what I'm suggesting is
maybe what we want is a different way of
displaying the
message so that the outer so that you
see both of these things so you can see
maybe it's in the dot dot dots you can
see the fact that it came from together
and it was a together
message
but you know the issue is what is that
word
there and then when you look underneath
here where you see the plot Co you know
let's say that said together blah blah
blah even though this was its you know
you know what I'm saying was its it's
that would be fine I think if if if we
can arrange you know manage that and it
doesn't mess up the messaging system and
documentation that that look and feel
would be fine I think okay so fine so
the question is well then there's the
question of which message name do you
use in check and of course also in in
you know a standalone kernel where you
don't have this repetition I think I
think then the answer to that is you get
the raw thing this is a pure decoration
this is a this is a pure piece of
wrapping paper that sounds like the
right thing yeah and can I ask because
I'm less familiar with you know the like
visualization system and what are you
calling the raw
thing I'm I'm saying the this the
together whatever it is the actual thing
of which this message is the is the
thing that's going to give you the
content of the message okay right so
you'll only ever see the the plot colon
colon if you're calling this in the
front
end you
mean yeah yes you'd only see the
decoration if you're doing it in the
front end probably I I don't know we
that's a different issue that's a
different issue we could imagine yet a
different you know way of displaying it
in a raw
kernel we could have lock plot colum
plot colum colum
tag yeah something like that except
we've used that for something else with
message uh different languages log plot
slash
plot like diing font size styling but I
wanted to ask
yeah what is the right way for us to
think about this I mean are we talk is
like to me it feels like it's something
like when one part of top level system
functionality is implemented using
another piece of top level system
functionality we're kind of trying to
hide that as like an implementation
detail is that the motivation yes that's
that's correct that's the motivation
it's it's what is the thing that is
taking
responsibility
versus I mean it's it's like it's like
the endless cases where somebody has
licensed some technology from some other
company and if you look inside you
discover it was from Fu Corporation but
on the outside all the wrapping says
it's bar
Corporation right so it's like white
labeled plot redistributed as as exactly
right
the yes all right we should wrap this
meeting but um okay well we we'll we'll
think this through and probably bring it
back to a future meeting sounds good all
right thanks a lot guys see you all soon
bye
thanks